Welcome to my home.
We're gonna.
Answer some questions for you today.
I got all your questions from the video.
You asked a lot of good stuff.
We're going to go through them for my
helper.
For this video.
We're going to use my sister,
Sydney,
the lovely Sydney Boucek.
You can call her the kidney and uh,
yeah.
So coffee on a Tuesday and 52.
Yeah.
Alright.
You guys asked a lot of great questions
here.
Um,
we're going to go through a couple of
them are going to answer as many as we
can,
as quickly as we can and hopefully we
can get through as many as possible.
Who is your favorite philosopher and
why?
Albert [inaudible].
Albert can move the myth,
the myth of sisyphus and the rebel.
Those are the two that really have
influenced me.
The most name,
some not so popular youtube channels
that you would recommend.
Well,
I have one chip.
So popular.
I have one channel that I,
that's really not so popular that I
think you guys would love.
It's called Nick Pucek.
Oh yes.
Next check.
Check it out.
Or Dad does a youtube channel.
He makes sand castles in the,
um,
in the summer,
just just subscribed to them.
It'll make them happy sports.
This is what I got to say about that.
Oh,
love
is your favorite book you've read in the
past year.
The fault in our stars.
Any advice for someone who is,
for lack of a better term,
still searching for what they love.
I think that if people have a passion
for something that may not,
for example,
writing that's not going to pay the
bills,
that they just,
they don't do it.
It might not pay the bills that might
not pay the bills.
They don't do it.
And then they just go for the job.
That's gonna pay the bills.
So
yeah,
I think there's a lot of hobbies that
you get that you think that,
that you just sort of enjoy.
You think you could never turn it into a
career just because of the way that you
were raised with the way that you think.
Everything that you do that you love can
be turned into a career if you do it
creatively.
Enough of the ancient Greek philosophers
who was the most awesome and why Plato,
because he was the best writer.
How is your brain the way your mind
works and your worldview different now
than when you were 18?
Because now you're 24.
I think the big difference between the
difference I think is that now I am
willing to be wrong,
to make someone happy,
whereas when I was 18,
I was obsessed with being right and the
truth.
So true.
So now I think the best thing that you
can do,
you are.
You always had to be right.
The best thing that you can do and
learn,
the hardest thing to learn is that
sometimes it's right to be wrong.
If it makes the other person happy.
Were you afraid of moving out on your
own and was it an easy adjustment?
No,
God,
I wanted to move out so bad when I came
to college.
Portland,
Oregon.
Well,
after college I went to Portland.
Yeah.
I just didn't want to live at home
anymore.
I tell that to people and my
relationship with my parents has become
exponentially better since I moved out.
So by the coop man,
get out.
What are your tips on starting a
vlogging channel?
Good audio.
Who is your favorite pokemon?
No question.
Chars art.
He's the most powerful and you can't
beat him.
Favorite movies?
Raging bull.
Anything by Tarkovsky 2001.
A space odyssey once upon a time in the
west.
Oh,
look who it is.
Yeah.
Progressive or conservative or Democrat
or Republican?
Probably.
He gets this.
I am A.
I'm a left of center Democrat,
which means I'm really close to the
center,
but on the left basically exactly what
President Obama is.
Do you follow any other vlogs on
Youtube?
Of course I follow the Vlog.
Brothers and weezy waiter,
Zay Frank.
I love Pten.
Check.
Nick pbs idea channel.
I love vsauce is just a few.
Um,
Brierley bishop,
great,
great bloggers.
I'm only people I aspire to be like,
how do you prevent procrastination?
Actually,
let me answer that question later.
What is your driving force?
Comfort,
knowledge,
revenge.
For me,
it's friendship name,
your top three bands,
the Beatles,
sly and the family stone.
And Bruce springsteen and thee street
band.
Beer or spirits.
What's your favorite poison?
What Scotch.
What are your religious beliefs?
Atheist.
What is your favorite novel of all time
and why?
The vira conium cycle,
but I'm John Harrison.
Read it.
My favorite book and the book that said
the most influence on me.
I don't know him.
John Harrison is and he's the best
writer of this generation.
If you could live in a movie and be a
certain character in a movie for a short
period of time,
I still hadn't thought of who would it
be and why?
I would be rick deckard in blade runner.
Why?
Why not?
How important was your education and
your career?
Let's talk about grades.
Well,
grades,
talk about grades.
Grades Don't matter.
I've always.
I used to go on tours of my college and
tell the kids who are thinking about
going to bu that.
Great,
so let's,
let's,
let's break it down now if you want to
be a doctor.
A lawyer requires Grad School,
Grad School,
grades batter.
Well,
see,
when I discovered grades didn't matter.
I didn't really try that hard in college
and then once I discovered that what he
said made sense,
I didn't try that hard in college and we
both have great jobs now.
Do you believe in true love?
Well,
we talk about this earlier.
I don't know if you're saying.
If you're asking me,
do I believe that love is true and real
then yes.
If you're asking,
do I believe in soulmates for for all of
us?
No.
I don't think there's so much.
There's not a soul mates.
You don't take.
Mom and dad are soulmates.
No.
I think this idea that there's like this
other puzzle piece,
soul out there for you to meet that's
searching through the world is insane,
insane idea.
Also,
I think that how to come.
They also many of met each other.
There's so many people in the world.
They put God really put the puzzle
pieces close together.
Yeah.
Advice for college,
freshmen and aspiring writers.
Okay.
Here's my advice for aspiring writers.
Learn how to deal with hating yourself.
Writing.
That's great advice.
Writing in the first weeks and months is
going to be a lot of hating yourself.
Probably six out of the seven days that
you write.
If you write all week,
you'll hate yourself.
That number will slowly shrink over time
and what you can do is really look
forward to the days when you think your
writing is good,
but you're always going to have those
days when you think your writing is
terrible and a lot of what stops writers
once they start is not being able to get
through those periods of days when what
you,
what you think you write is really shit
because it is really shit.
In the beginning you should get a second
opinion.
What did you think?
Your writing is really good,
but it's really not that good.
I always get a second opinion.
Would you rather fight one horse sized
duck or 100 duck sized horses?
I think the answer is obvious.
One weight,
one horse sized duck,
or 100 duck sized horses.
100 ducks side is.
I think there's no.
There's no argument about this.
It's 100 duck sized horses because you
just mow them down,
right?
Because you say you take a,
you take a golf club and was just
fucking mow them down.
Yeah.
Sorry.
It will be terrifying to face the duct
size horse or no,
it'd be terrifying to face a horse sized
stuck.
Think about this.
A horse.
A horse sized.
Yeah.
This is,
that's what it's doing.
What is the bravest thing you've ever
done?
The bravest thing I ever did was tell my
friends that I love them.
Why do you have to make everything sound
dramatic?
Like there was always some deeper
meaning to it when there is.
So actually the bid,
they were staying in these me to do it.
Thanks so much for the [inaudible],
for joining us for this.
This was a lot of fun.
And what we're going to do it again in
the future,
I promise.
Um,
and we will see you next time.
Next time.
Do you have any hidden talents?
I can unicycle.
That's.
I think that person just wanted to tell
me that they could do the cycle.
Oh,
they said I can't use the cycle.
What can I know you can.